Caroline Aghajanian: On this
episode of "Travel Dares,"
Aj Caldwell: I'm taking
Caroline to Zip World
to try the world's fastest zip line.
Caroline: And I'm here at
the Pontcysyllte Aqueduct,
where we're gonna canoe
126 feet in the air.
Come join us on our adventures
on this episode of "Travel Dares!"
Welcome to "Travel Dares!"
I'm Caroline, and in this episode,
we're in Wales with my friend Aj.
Aj: Wales is known for
its rolling countryside
and rich history, with some of the most
picturesque landscapes you'll ever see.
Caroline: I use my Marriott
Bonvoy Boundless card
on all of my trips so that I can earn
two times the points on
my everyday purchases.
Aj, how excited are you?
Aj: I am so excited!
Are you ready for your first clue?
Caroline: So ready.
OK, very clever.
Oh, I hope I have a helmet for this, Aj,
if it's head-first.
Aj: You'll be OK.
Caroline: I don't know, "head first"?
I don't know, I feel like
you are very adventurous,
so I feel like we might be bungee jumping.
Aj: Caroline's never done
anything like this before,
and even though it'll be
a little intimidating,
it's the perfect way to push her
out of her comfort zone.
I'm gonna set you right there.
You stay there.
Caroline: Oh, my gosh.
I feel like we're really high up.
There's a railing.
Aj: Uh, you know.
(zips zipper)
Caroline: You're wearing
something, you're definitely
wearing something. That
was a zipper. Oh, my gosh.
Aj: You can take your blindfold off.
Caroline: OK, OK.
Aj: Because we're going down
the world's fastest zip line.
Caroline: Oh, my gosh!
Oh, my gosh!
What?
I'm so, this is so high up.
Tim Pennington: Zip World's Velocity 2
is the most unique ride.
It's the longest ride in
the Northern Hemisphere.
We have got the world record
for the fastest zip line in the world.
We've broken that record twice, now.
The zip line takes
approximately 56 seconds
to do one mile and drop over 1,200 feet.
Aj: All right. How do I look?
Caroline: You look great! How do I look?
Aj: You look good, too.
Caroline: Woo!
We are on our way to the big boy.
Aj: The big one!
Caroline: It is, uh. Yeah,
we're just a tad bit nervous.
Aj: Eh, just a little bit.
But you know what? No turning back now.
We have to do it.
It literally feels like
we're on top of the world.
This is so breathtaking.
Oh, my gosh!
Aj: Look at them!
Caroline: They're going so fast!
You know what, I just
can't think about it.
I just have to go.
Let's just go.
Aj: Let's do it.
Caroline: Let's do it, let's do it!
Aj: Let's do it!
Caroline: OK.
Here I go. OK.
Oh, my gosh, OK.
I think I'm just getting strapped in now.
Aj, where are you?
Aj: I'm over here.
Caroline: Getting strapped in.
Uh-oh.
It's a lot higher from this angle.
Aj: Here we go.
(laughing)
Here we go.
Caroline: It's like we're levitating!
Aj: I know!
Instructor: Safeties on.
Caroline: Uh-oh.
Instructor: All right, let's go, guys.
OK, three, two, one.
(screaming)
Aj: Yeah!
Caroline: That was so much fun!
The view!
When you first, like,
step off the platform,
it feels like this is the end.
It's the last thing you're gonna see.
And then you start picking up speed,
and it just gets so much better.
It just gets, like, so relaxing
and you just get to sit
and just stare at the view around you.
Aj, that was so much fun!
Thank you so much for bringing me here.
Aj: Caroline, you were so brave today,
I'm so impressed.
Caroline: Everyone talks about
how Wales is so beautiful,
and, honestly, I think this
is the best way to see it.
Aj, your clue.
Aj: All right, here we go.
So we're going up high, it's heights.
Caroline: Uh, you just
have to wait and see
until we get there.
Aj: OK, so it's gonna be,
like, skydiving?
Don't look down?
I think we're gonna like,
dangle off something
or be pushed off something
or jump off something really high?
Caroline: Aj loves thrill
rides, and the combination
of the intense height
with the zen activity
is something he's never done before.
This adventure is gonna be the perfect way
for Aj to see the Welsh countryside.
Aj: All right.
Caroline: All right.
OK, you stand here.
Take off your blindfold,
'cause we are going canoeing
over 120 feet in the air!
Aj: Are you kidding?
This is so cool!
Caroline: And we're
headed in that direction.
Andy Turton: All right then, welcome
to the Pontcysyllte Aqueduct.
So, are you guys ready to go?
Aj: Yeah, I'm ready!
Caroline: Yeah,
I'm totally ready. Let's do it!
Andy: Brilliant. This is an amazing way
to get quite a thrill-seek,
from going canoeing on a canal
to then paddle 126 foot above the river,
with the sheer sideage,
to look over is quite,
quite impressive to be able to do.
It's great that we've got
it to be able to do it here.
Caroline: Pro tip: Don't fall, yeah.
Aj: All right.
Caroline: OK, we just
can't shake the boat, Aj.
Aj: Yeah, don't rock the boat.
Caroline: Lean!
Aj: I'm very excited,
I'm a little nervous,
but I'm really excited to see this view.
Caroline: All right, and we're...
Aj: I think I hear, like, a stream?
Caroline: Yeah, same.
Oh, it's a river!
Aj: It's a river below us!
Caroline: We're paddling.
Aj: We're paddling over a river.
Caroline: Over a river.
We're on a river, on a river.
Aj: I wanna, you wanna look over?
Caroline: We're on the
big boy bridge. Yeah.
Aj: I wanna look over here.
Caroline: Uh-oh, we're getting risky!
We're getting risky here, Aj!
Aj: Oh, my gosh.
Look at this.
Caroline: Wow.
We are higher than the birds right now.
Aj: We are literally
higher than the birds.
There's birds flying below us.
Caroline: This is beautiful.
Lynda Slater: It's the
highest and the longest
in Great Britain, of the aqueducts.
It's obviously been
standing for over 200 years.
It's a significant feat of engineering.
It's why it's been, dominated
all the World Heritage Sites.
In fact, we're celebrating
10 years of having
World Heritage Site
subscription this year.
Aj: You know, I think the
views here and at Zip World
are two of the most beautiful
views you can see in Wales.
Caroline: Honestly, I think this is one of
the most serene views I've ever seen.
Aj, did you have a good time?
Aj: Oh, it was dope!
I loved it so much.
Caroline: I'm so glad.
I had such an amazing time in Wales.
It was both of our first time here,
and it was way more beautiful
than I thought it would be.
Aj: There is no better way
to end our UK experience
than with a nice cup of tea
back at the hotel.
Caroline: This is actually
the oldest hotel in Bristol.
It's, like, 150 years old.
Aj: Really? That's very classy.
Caroline: Aj, how do you
think I did on my dare?
Aj: Well, when I revealed
that we were going
down the world's fastest zip line,
I really thought you were gonna be scared,
but you were actually really excited,
even when we got to the
top of the mountain,
staring down 1,500
meters of zip-line cable.
You were excited and ready to go.
So, for that,
I'm giving you five out of five stars.
Caroline: Yes!
I love a good five out of five stars.
Thank you, no, it was really fun.
It was such an exhilarating feeling
and the views were beautiful,
so I really, really did enjoy it.
Aj: Caroline, I had a great time,
but I have to know, what is my rating?
Caroline: OK, so, honestly,
Aj, I was really impressed
with how well you handled this dare.
You went straight to the front of the boat
and you canoed really well,
and you even looked over the bridge
and you weren't even scared.
So, for those reasons, Aj, you're getting
a five out five stars!
Aj: Yes, that's what I wanted!
Caroline: Aj, finish your tea
because we have a flight to catch.
Aj: I am so ready for this next dare.
Caroline: Pinkies up.
(clink)